[Music]
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
move your channel tonight we're having
an sg-1 quiz
and these two muppets
that way no i always get this wrong
because the camera's upside down
have self-professed as stargate masters
they know everything
matt who runs our discord has more than
once to me said that if he doesn't he
gets any questions at all wrong that
he's a complete loser and we should all
mock him mercilessly
at this channel
[Laughter]
so tonight these two
dom and matty from the discord server
i'm gonna go head to head they have 40
questions
if one of them gets the answer wrong
or doesn't know
the other person will get a chance to
steal a point
so this could be pretty close or one
person could end up running miles away
with this um
we will get stuck in pretty quick but i
will tell you before we came on
these two young gentlemen had a question
that question was how long in meters is
the prometheus now this was to decide
who gets to go first
dominic won because matt how long did
you think the prometheus was
fifteen hundred meters because it's
of course
actually 195 meters so
dominic got the uh got the answer right
hello shelly hello wakey
uh the man among the commoners good
evening right so
should we just get stuck into it yes
so the first question goes to dominic
uh how wide is the stargate in meters
and i will accept within um half a meter
meters
do you think
the the star gate is 38 meters okay
matt no no no damn it
yes yeah no we'll go 38 meters
yeah matt same question to you sir how
wide you think the stargate is in meters
within half a meter
two meters
no you are also incorrect i'm afraid the
diameter of the width of the stargate is
6.7 meters
nilpoi
it was obviously last night so
matt you get the second question sir who
played colonel frank simmons in stargate
sg1
colonel frank simmons
oh i don't know that's one warning i
don't know
who played
colonel simmons
uh well that was the q actor um
i'm trying to think of his name um
um
matthew no no the answer
the answer is john de lancie john de
lancie that's the great john de lancie
still nilpoi what a good start okay
gentlemen
to you dominic
valamaldaran was host to a gold symbiote
much like scara was to clarel what was
the name of the gold which shared her
body
oh my nose matt no it's no question of
dominic but matt knows
oh what is it um
uh
hello my um
please don't give them the answers in
the comments guys until after i've told
you the answer
so they'll cheat
so what was her name
10 second warning
no i don't know
well i do know if i don't remember
to steal
kate
it was kate
okay okay
so matt your question
uh in season one the members fg-1 meet
an advanced race called the knox
what is the name of the young boy with
the group they meet
i didn't know these are hard i didn't
believe you
was going to be hard you guys said you
were super geeks oh
i didn't know this one when i read it i
don't know
fast
dominic there's a chance to steal
i think
so the girl was the uh
the really nice one so i think um
i will i will give you a point for
mafereu
which i think is new enough is that how
it said i'm not i can't remember how
they say it n-a-f-r-a-y-u
yes
so question number five
this one is to
dominic
the leader of sg9 set himself up as god
on a planet of primitives in which
episode
um
it was a bit it was a
it was uh
i think
um
was married to her what was engaged to
him um
no don't know
to steal matt
i don't know the name of the episode but
i'm
oh
i i know that i know the episode was it
called the episode's name was
last chance no
no pass the episode was the commandment
okay question number six
uh this one is to matt
complete the quote you didn't think the
colonel's a telescope in his roof just
to hmm
did you
uh look at his neighbors or stare at his
neighbors look at his neighbors well
done matt you got one right look at that
quick oh we're off now you're smashing
it you're gonna go through this now
dominic
this is question number
seven
which i have to find there we go
what does martin attempt to contact who
does martin attempt to contact at the
sgc
colonel jack o'neill
colonel jack o'neil
dominic gets a point
oh it's nick and nick at the moment guys
question number eight
who is the first member of the sg-1 to
meet jennifer haley
who's answering this
this is tomat
uh sam
it is sam
well done i should ask for a full name
really i'm so joking
dominic
question number nine
what season seven episode did amanda
tapping direct and michael shanks write
oh oh uh
uh
i think it was the um second last
episode of the season seven
um
which was um
so it's the last it was the second last
episode i'm pretty sure
um
ten seconds
it was um it was about the girl with the
with snake in her head uh identity i
think
certainly that is incorrect matt
any idea
no idea
no clue the episode name was i've lost
it
i don't don't turn the page one second
resurrection
nil point
question number 10 this one is to matt
which a doc which egyptian goddess was
the daughter of ra
hathor
i thought well done matt
okay at the end of the first round
dominic has a massive score of
matty has a score of
four i don't know how
i genuinely have no clue how
i think you're cheating i don't know why
or how but i think you cheated
but
i'm i'm one with the replicators that's
why
[Laughter]
so the next round again
dominick you're going to be starting um
if i get mixed up with the order please
help me out um
the two questions that i've written
first
who said mayborn you are an idiot every
day of the week couldn't you just take
one day off
well at the time she was i believe
captain samantha carter but she might
have been a major at that point
it was in the episode uh the uh i've got
hold
hold yeah well then sir
um i got that wrong i put and i caught a
kneel
and i did yeah well that's what i
thought i was thinking of neil straight
away but then
uh when you said about the idiot part um
i instantly remembered it's the scene
where she was in the cafe waiting for
him to turn up and then he turns up with
conor neal and daniel jackson perfect
for limitations
so question number four to matthew
how many sg-1 episodes aired and i will
give you 10 either way
in total uh
214
bang on
i didn't even need to give you a leeway
well done sir
okay then so question number 13
amanda tapping's real-life husband
appeared in an episode at sg-1 which one
and that is to dominic
i will give you a hint this episode
by christopher judge the what sorry
it would help if i knew who her husband
was
oh i can't help but actually there's
another hint that um they won't help you
christopher judge's girlfriend also
appeared in this episode
five seconds no clue no the episode was
called the change changeling
and christopher amanda tapping's husband
played alan a fireman
there you go
um
this team initially led by colonel
robert make beast this is to uh dominic
uh no this did matthew's new sorry
uh this team initially led by colonel
robert make peace was primarily designed
as a combat team man completely by us
marines
which team
sg-12
incorrect dominic
can you ask the question again please
certainly
this team initially led by colonel
robert make peace
was primarily designed as a combat team
manned completely by us marines
name the team
sg3
correct
stole a point i've just i accidentally
gave it to matthew though so let me come
back
who plays uh this is to
uh dominic
no
yeah yes dynamic um who plays peter
williams i'm sorry who does peter
williams play
peter williams
um
it's not
uh
pete
shanahan
that's wrong
matt
to steal
apophis
well done
to matthew
the next question is
baylor reappears pregnant at the end of
series nine she was impregnant in real
life
who was the father in the series not in
real life her husband was a father in
real life in the show who was the father
is this to me
yes to matty
i feel like his name's like tomin
something like that
i think that was the boyfriend
incorrect
dominic
well her boyfriend's
husband was tomin uh but it was actually
the uh all-right that impregnated her
i might give you that because it was an
immaculate conception
so
i'm gonna give you that
is it you're right with that matthew
yeah that's fine that's fair enough yeah
god did it
so dominic hallowed are you all right
hello the other one 17. what is the
correct translation
what is the correct translation of
phallatus in this sentence i have lost
the philatus to speak
the ability to speak
i've lost the ability to speak
dominic is pulling it back he's pulling
it back matt
be worried
intangent the episode tangent oh sorry
this is to uh matthew again in tangent
the x 301 is codenamed what
code
steal dominic
by can you ask the question again please
yes in tangent the x 301 is codenamed
what
uh it was a
code named i thought the codename was
uh well it was an experimental us air
force fighter
er effect interceptor um
[Music]
codenamed um
oh oh oh i know you already know i mean
uh digger one
digger one is correct
hold on
be worried mate you perform behind there
okay so
question two dominic
in the season one episode tin man the
team encountered the artificial being
harlan
what is the greeting he uses
contraire
controller
i think that's how i said
there is spot on that
question 18
while uh
matt while major carter and jacob carter
salmek were attempting to develop an
advanced weapon the alpha sight was
destroyed which of the following enemies
led to its destruction
was it the zatrak a jaffa spy the
replicators or a call warrior
can you just say the
um enemies again while major carter and
jacob carter salman were attempting to
develop an advanced weapon the alpha
site was destroyed which of the
following enemies led to its destruction
um a zatak a zafa spy replicators or a
call warrior
the first one
the zatak
yeah incorrect dominic
uh it was the uh anubis warriors the uh
the
uh the last one he said i think whole
warriors
one two three four five six seven
your current score is nine
your current score matthew
is six
right match when we said that you were
brilliant at this and
you run our you are actually a member of
the team god damn it
come on
i will i will re-watch target
yeah
i have been mean with these questions
they are tough
so all right
so
really i thought i said we've got a
comment on the thing of a guy's got 17
points at the moment really good i
thought it was kenneth branagh i thought
we had a really famous
viewer then for a second but kenneth
bruner is destroying both of you
so next question
this one will be for dominic first
who commanded the bc 304 korolev
is this for me
no it's just
dominic's always first because
kennel check off
i always love that one i just love that
it's check off so as soon as i saw that
question i was just like i'm having that
that's brilliant
okay so
now this should be an easy one man you
should get this okay you ready for this
one you should really really get this
one okay okay are you ready yeah it's
really easy who wrote children of the
gods
brad wright
and
robert c cooper
incorrect
dominance
no incorrect
i don't know
matt um patrick steele
there were two writers
uh so what was the answers you just gave
sorry
he said brad wright and joseph melosi
okay
i think it was i know definitely bad
right because he was one of the main
producers uh jonathan
uh
glassman
which i think last night wrote
with brad wright
the main two producers of the first few
series
just saying
right
um actor this one is to
uh oh god i've given metric matt point
then just out of habit sorry um patrick
this is your ass
actor gary jones plays which part in
stargate sg1 sergeant harriman the
technician norman davis all of these
sorry say that again actor gary jones
plays what part in stargate sg-1
sergeant harriman the technician norman
davis all of them
all of
them
correct
question number 24
really need to go to run at the moment
matt
to
matthew
when a tense situation calls for
diplomatic specialties who does general
hammond call for ysg team
sg6
no i'm sorry it's incorrect dominic
um well that was the second season
um in where the prisoners i think it was
called the episode so i think
um
sg14
incorrect
the answer was sg9
oh
my god that was this my first song
um
to
dominic how much does it cost to run the
stargate program
i think it was senator kinsey
told us this
i think it was about
17 million
per day or something like that
seven zero
yeah 70 million incorrect and this is
per annum we've got but go on matt give
it a go
well it's something like 4 billion
just to keep the lights on or something
like that yeah 7.4 billion
is the correct answer
question number 26
see it's not easy i told you i was going
to make it difficult for you
but then i do throw in the odd question
just for matt
[Laughter]
what planet is teal from
is this for me
this is for matt
julac
lick
well done
i should i should have got it wrong on
purpose
i know but you didn't there you go
for dominic a slightly tougher one what
is the name of the prison sg-1 is sent
to in the season 2 episode prisoners
ah
ten seconds
uh well the translation was uh
they've been sent to hell um it's what
daniel said um
but the name of it
tardan
spell it
uh
t-a-r
uh
that's incorrect sir dominic matthews to
steal
no no chance
hedante
question number 28
this one is for matthew which greek
titan was the father of zeus
we do see him obviously he's one of the
gold
particularly shitty one i don't know i
think i know i think i know
his name what's his name
i can't think of his name
five
four
three
two
dominic
i think it's camus
incorrect i'm afraid the answer is
cronus cloners
bugger
question number 29.
up until the end of series six this is
gonna be this is an interesting one i
didn't have a clue on this one up until
the end of season six oh this is to
dominic
um samantha carter had how many love
interests
by the end of series six how many love
interests had she had
love interests
uh well she had okay so let's let's get
on the side so you had um the choker you
had uh
her ex-husband or ex-fiance that's two
um
you had
jack free
um p
four i'm going to say with
incorrect
map
i'm going with three
oh it's five you went the wrong way
you went the wrong way you're so close
so close uh there's a long list here but
she was basically a little bit of a
black widow because almost all of them
died
yeah
so
um question number 32 matt
um sakai had a prisoner it had a prison
called natu or hell which is what i
think you would think about earlier
dominic
but which planet did it orbit
so sokka had a prison called natu or
hell but what planet did it orbit
hmm
i've got no idea
i probably know it as well and you're
gonna say and i want to go oh no i
passed
dominic to steal
what's the the name of the the the the
present time
network
uh is it
uh it's a dell mac
dalmac is correct
that round you got five points patrick
and that you are fourteen
i don't want that you've got none
i've got one which question did you get
right cue luck
of course you did
i forgot to write it down oh make sorry
i've given you um
i'm trying to get it don't worry
you've got 13
and matt you have
seven
yep okay we are going to play the
observation round before we go into the
final round of the quiz
okay so here is going to be a little
video for you
there will be a series of questions at
the end of the video
um you will have a few seconds to answer
each one
so here is the video i think you'll
enjoy this clip because personally i
don't know you guys it's pretty much my
favorite
here you go
three ends with a reference to perennial
adventists
you've been over this
i believe it means the approaching
disaster
[Music]
of the machine itself with recurring use
the machine
[Music]
surrenders to the rigors of time
it's incorrect no jackson
[Music]
the word abc a room means to give up
not surrender
okay this section of the text seems to
deal primarily with their arrival on
p4x639
okay this section of the text seems to
deal primarily with their arrival on
p4x639
now this word here
uh deductive is a variation of deduct
okay this section of the text seems to
deal primarily with their arrival on
p4x639
this appears to be a reference to the
gradual degenerations of the machine
itself
the foundation of a colony
[Music]
guys you getting this because this is
important
[Music]
who knew
should we not be assisting daniel
jackson with the translation
i'm taking this loop off
[Applause]
we don't find a way out of this soon i'm
gonna lose it
lose it
it means go crazy
nuts
insane
bonzo
no longer in possession of one's
factories three fries short of a happy
meal
thank you no no thank you
exactly how many of these loops have you
have we
been through
i've lost track
that must be frustrating
uh
yeah
on the other hand it is kind of an
opportunity
how's that
well think about i mean if you know in
advance that everything is always going
to go back to the way it was then
you could do anything
for as long as you want without having
to
worry about consequences
[Music]
excuse me
[Music]
oh yeah
that'll play
[Music]
how far is alaris anyway
several billion miles
that's gotta be a record
so
[Music]
sorry sir i didn't realize
excuse me george
carol what are you doing out of your
import
handing you my resignation
resigning
so i can do
this
sorry that was so much longer than i
realized but it's the greatest scene
that felt like half the episode watching
it back there though
right
in the episode i was thinking
when you thought it was not yes i was
thinking one of my favorites
right so i'm just talking where i am
gave a couple of questions now based on
that
patrick first oh dominic first sorry i
keep cleaning patrick dominic first what
is the planet dan daniel mentions
the planet
uh
do you want the um you know the uh p4
thing anything or do you want the name
of the planet
over there that's what he mentions
that's what he says
uh
p4
x
639
well done dominic so i'm always taking
notes
matthew
what color is o'neill's hat when he
kisses carter
i did not make a note about that yellow
his jumper was yellow i'm afraid his hat
was
black i'm not going to exchange on this
one
how many um pots does ken o'neil try to
make
matthew at dominic sir
including the one he had in the
background uh i'd say there was those
four about four in the background one he
was making so five but then obviously he
went through this thing about a hundred
times so
time to buy a hundred i guess if if you
wanna do the windows he did in in the
video the questions how many does he do
you'd see him making basically how much
he tried to make
so you see him making two
in the clip oh two okay
matthew
um
where are they driving the balls to
they're hitting the golf balls where are
they hitting them
laras
well done
um
dominic what are they juggling
uh
uh base baseball balls
incorrect just screwed up balls of paper
oh
um matthew surrender to the rigors of
time o'neill corrects jackson what does
surrender correctly translate to
to give up
to give up
is this your round we should have done
this more
here we go right how many golf balls get
hit to alarus dominic
how many do we see get hit
uh
i'm gonna say
uh
two
two is correct he's about to hit the
third one when yeah
and that's why
in the middle of my backswing
let's do the last question what color a
teal golf
gear where what was he wearing blue
oh
no he's wearing cream or tan whatever
we're going to call it beige whatever
you want to call it
so after that one patrick got two
matthew got
two
into the final round and at the moment
it is 15
against nine
so matt you're gonna have to you need
some pull backs you need some you need
some tricky ones here maybe i'm gonna
have to give you this afterwards
what what that
it's a it's a crown oh very nice well
done
um so dominic first as always
uh richard dean anderson had a real-life
injury written into the episode
redemption
what was the injury
uh he broke his shoulder
that's incorrect matthew
for the steel
he hurt his back
that's also incorrect i've already
busted his knee
so he had and he was all strapped up he
was carrying his three-year-old daughter
he slipped and he busted his knee
um tom macbeth played who
uh to matthew
tom macbeth
one of the great characters
i don't know
dominic to the steel
i think it was a
colonel
howard mabon
it was meborn
um
what did you call in there
uh there's nothing called um
how old mabon whether uh ldl i called
him harry but i bet it would be harold
okay i'll give you oh i actually think
it was harold i think you're right i got
harry but yeah
okay so now we're gonna move
and
patrick stole one
okay
back to the
questions
that one so to dominic
who is the first takra that sg-1 meets
topra sorry who is the first tokera that
sg-1 meets
you could definitely call it a meeting
um
i'm thinking it's jalanna uh because she
went into
sam and then some became the toke for
herself so i'm assuming it's drama
if not it would be the uh
uh
it's correct well done
what gold to matthew what gold is the
son of hathor and ra
apophis
harura
or hero
yeah yeah i'll make i'm sorry i should
have posted overseas dominic sorry mate
um no problem i gave you the opportunity
to steal then and i i messed it up for
you apologies
dominic you're well in the lead though
so worried about it
um
35
with flying through this dominic in the
episode desperate measures what does the
homeless guy oh no sorry i decided not
to ask that because i think it's
absolutely impossible
let me go through there's the next one
in the season two episode holiday which
stargate sg1 star played machello
[Music]
no i don't i don't know
matt to steal
michelle
you want the actor's name the actor's
name
listen to the question though
in the season two episode holiday which
stargate sg1 star played micello
uh michael shanks
michael shanks
please everyone in the
comments they can see your comments to
be a bit slower with the
answers
so
i'm just giving it patrick
there we go
next question
which of the following to dominic this
is sorry no sorry to matthew which of
the following is the egyptian god of
chaos osiris anubis baal or seth
mr matthew
seth
the answer is seth well done
dominic
which race of aliens were the first host
of the gold and of course problems on
several occasions for the sg-1
uh unas
the unass
correct
matthew
who did daniel jackson tell to
a little less talk and a little more
shut the hell up
who is he talking to
oh
dominic
uh jack o'neill
incorrect
who do you think he's talking to when he
says something like that
oh i thought it was the episode with uh
where um um what's his name uh the guy
um
who who got taken in the children of the
gods um
apotheca's son what's his name
so to dominic this is your last question
of the game what is the name of the girl
carter saved
say
oh uh cassandra
cassandra
correct
and final question
o'neill this is to you matthew o'neill
is training young dead when he learns of
a possible alien incursion at the sgc
what is the name of that episode
foothold desperate measures fail safe or
proving ground
proving ground
the answer is proving ground well done
and that is the end of our little sg1
quiz
at the end of that quiz matthew you got
12 points
which i feel is brave
and i mean this is out of 48 don't
forget but that no no it's not is it you
only had 25
24 out of 24. so that's not bad actually
not quite as good as our young dominic
who did get 19 points
out of 24.
boom back up
there you go you get your crown
so
dominique
yeah you are the
i would love to invite you guys back
in a few weeks maybe to do a stargate
atlantis quiz
that's perfect i can do that i'm a big
fan of slugger asu why not lenses and
universe
i know universe is a touchy topic for
most people but uh i was actually quite
a big fan of it
i loved it even though it annoyed me at
times it's still stargate yeah the only
the only problem i had with with that
one is that it was so much violence
you know i mean the the the leader was
so angry all the time with with rush and
it's like
that's not really going to help this is
what's going behind
how they used to bat the crap out of
each other i thought that was great i
loved it
um uh did it was gonna say
and my only problem with sg was that it
was boring
so that's maybe a slightly different
problem
yeah i i get where you're coming from i
mean the second season was definitely an
improvement on the first 100 um so even
though they didn't do as much exploring
they actually you know they they had
that great new enemy with the mini
robots gonna try and kill them all and
you know
it felt like stargate towards the end of
the season um yeah exactly yeah it i
think it was just getting better as they
when they got cancelled um i have got
one question for you on stargate
atlantis that i learned about today do
you know one of the big reasons why
stargate atlantis was cancelled
nothing to do with them viewing figures
um
wasn't it that they were they wanted to
make a movie
yeah they were going to make seasons uh
they were going to make the movie um
which then they thought about turning
into the beginning of season six
um
but then they sort of they got cancelled
because
uh mgm was going bust or something i
think it was it was financial reasons
but it was in big part because you know
obviously they filmed in vancouver and
british columbia
um
initially that was a huge cost savings
for them when they set up there but then
as the economy changed the exchange rate
between america and canada just got
worse and worse so it was actually in
real terms the show was actually
becoming really expensive
they tried to move the show and wanted
to move the show back to la but because
everything was set up the sound stages
everything else
it was too expensive
that's why we lost our goat atlantis
because
uh
post recently he's done on twitter um
regarding
what would have been atlantis season six
yeah and the amazing discoveries they
would have found
um and it just honestly it sounds
like the best stargate you'd ever watch
yeah well it was like my favorite
episode that was on there was one called
like
future present something sometimes
through the future present past where
there's three versions of the team split
between multiple times oh yes the the
deadliest variations
yeah yeah it was it was yeah something
to do with that yeah because because of
the aliens that they've met there
something to do with that but yeah
yes it would be uh
atlantis uh when they were already on
their way back to earth
um but there's no crew and it was
actually an alternate alternate
alternate alternate alternate reality
version of it
um
yeah they love those mirror universes
they gotta love them
you nearly got a couple of mirror
universal questions today but i thought
it was getting a bit confusing so i i
missed him out
guys seriously thank you so much for
joining um it really has been um a
delight
um it's been a lot of fun i can't lie
yeah thank you i'm sorry the questions
are too hard for you matt's not dominic
if you ever need a hand on your uh
stargate discord server just let me know
yeah
come in come and join i'll make you a
mod it's fine
there you go happy days
uh if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit the bell notification
do all those things
please go and join the discord server
and there is a link on our facebook
group and you can also go join us on the
facebook group that would be lovely
um there should be a link to the discord
server in the um description
but i think i forgot
so
i'll post it i'll post it in the chat
now don't look so horrified mate i'll
add it
so um
you need to set up your upload defaults
i did it i i have done but it doesn't
work when i go through good live streams
there we go i post it in uh
excellent thank you very much and i will
add the um
dispatch the description there yeah when
you have to do a live stream you have to
set it up completely differently so the
upload doesn't work
um but anyway
thank you very much guys really really
appreciate it um we will obviously be
back to do this again if um if you guys
are willing and in the meantime i have
to try to do what i always do and find
the outro there we go found it
really really appreciate it and all hail
psytrek stargate quizzes
master of all
our young dominic
with his purpose
i love how you've colored your hair
purple to match our logo and it's not of
course of course why wouldn't you you
know you want to blend in
yeah core corporate colors you've come
in with so thank you i was going to do
that but
[Laughter]
oh you could get away with it just get a
sharpie on there and you know
we'll call you in
good night both and thank you very much
say good night guys good night good
night guys have a good day
[Music]
you